let's go next to our caller from the a
four one five area code is what's four
one five is that San Francisco yeah
Santa Cisco I'm also a first-time voter
and I'm going to be voting in the 2020
primaries Grum and so I kind of had a
question about the candidate and
authenticity I was just wondering
because he's seem like some gasps I
guess you could call it or questions
whether it's Elizabeth Warren awkwardly
drinking beer or Carla Harris like Miss
naming the music she listened to in
college or the Cory Booker making up a
fake drug dealer I was just I was just
wondering if that's something that
Candice
okay you're breaking you're breaking up
probably what you're breaking up you
what we heard is you're wondering if
that's something that what if it's
something important to you in a
candidate its authenticity is it
important to me yes listen
authenticity is important all else being
equal I would rather a candidate where I
believe that the public persona somewhat
closely matches who that person really
is is that ever the case no I mean I try
to be as authentic as possible on the
David Pakman show am i 100% authentic
self on the show no it's a slightly it's
it's there's some deviation from that
right so I think number one we should
have reasonable expectations when people
are running for president on a national
stage is it reasonable to imagine that
they are going to be the exact same way
that they are in their living room with
their family no that's not reasonable
but what we should be paying attention
to is is the platform that they are
espousing a platform that they actually
believe in because if not if they've
ended up with a particular platform
instead of policy positions because of
either how polling is pointing or
because of corporate interests or
whatever as quickly as they got into
that platform they could get out of it
for equally poor reasons so to that
extent authenticity is important if
someone is for Medicare for all it's
more important I prefer that they be for
it because
they believe in it rather than because
they think it's the right thing to say
for the 2020 primary if that makes sense
is something like awkwardly drinking
beer or whatever going to change my
opinion about a candidate as president
no it's not but I am going to consider
how that might impact voters how is that
going to make them a target for Donald
Trump conceivably or something like that
right I totally agree but I find that
especially on the left it's always been
about just pushing politicians to a
position that's closer to ours and I
think that you know we should let
politicians change positions and that's
the nature of politics and just
pressuring them into our direction yeah
well now you're in so just the idea of
is is changing one's view on something
objectively bad and of course the answer
is no we want the views to change though
because they're better informed not
because some lobbying group said hey
we're gonna cut the money unless you
change your mind alright very good
thanks for the call great to hear from
people in the Bay Area of course